Spider-Man is headed back to Sony, and the
guys who helped bring him into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are disappointed, but not
surprised.
During a recent conversation with The Daily
Beast, Avengers: Endgame directors Joe and
Anthony Russo shared their thoughts on the
web-slinger's unceremonious exit from the
biggest film franchise in history.
The pair related that while they and Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin Feige had been absolutely
driven to bring Spidey into their universe,
the shared custody deal with Sony was an extremely
difficult one to get done, so difficult that
negotiations to extend it falling apart didn't
register to them as being terribly surprising.
Peter Parker appeared in the MCU for the first
time in the Russo Brothers' second Marvel
flick: Captain America: Civil War.
From the beginning of the project's development,
the directors were adamant that the story
should include Spider-Man, despite the obvious
stumbling block of Sony holding the film rights.
Anthony Russo said,
"We were extremely passionate about it.
This is something we really wanted to happen,
and fought a long time internally at Marvel
to make it happen."
There were, of course, contingencies in the
very likely event that a deal wouldn't be
struck.
Black Panther, who was also introduced in
Civil War, would have had his role greatly
expanded in the event that Spidey couldn't
come out to play, and several other narrative
elements would have been different as well.
The movie's script went through several iterations
as all of the involved parties were attempting
to reach an agreement, and poor Feige was
right in the middle of it all, attempting
to juggle the creative and business sides
of his job in a way that he hadn't been asked
to do before.
Joe Russo said,
"Kevin went through a lot.
There were a lot of ups and downs, and he
kept walking into our office and we'd go,
'Look, we've got to do it with [Sony],' and
he'd go, 'OK, I'll figure it out,' and walk
back into his.
He was looking for the way out.
He wanted to open that door and have us go,
'We figured it out!
We don't need Spider-Man!' because it's a
lot of work to get two major corporations
to play nice with each other, and the fact
that it happened at all, we should all be
dancing and celebrating that we got that little
bit of time."
Anthony Russo agreed, saying,
"I think that's why Joe and I are not so devastated
or surprised that there's been a falling out,
because it was so hard to make it happen in
the first place."
The Russos make an excellent point; the fact
that we got two solo and three team-up adventures
featuring Spider-Man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is in itself a minor miracle.
But this doesn't do much to ease the broken
hearts of the franchise's fans, who had wanted
Tom Holland's Peter Parker to stick around
in the MCU for just a little longer.
"I don't want to go, I don't want to go, sir,
please!
Please, I don't want to go.
I don't want to go."
The matter, though, appears to have been settled.
Sony Pictures chairman and CEO Tony Vinciquerra
threw cold water on any remaining dreams fans
might have with remarks he recently made at
Variety's Entertainment and Technology Summit,
saying, quote, "For the moment the door is
closed."
Vinciquerra also expressed the extremely optimistic
view that Spider-Man will do "just fine" in
the Sony Universe of Marvel Characters, without
help from Marvel Studios.
Because, sure!
Who needs the Avengers when you have Morbius
and Silver Sable?
"What is this place?!"
To be fair, Venom did do pretty darn well
at the box office, although it got nowhere
near the critical love that even the worst-received
MCU films have.
We suppose it'll be cool to see Tom Hardy's
Eddie Brock and Holland's Peter Parker squaring
off, but let's face facts: after the debacle
that was the rebooted Amazing Spider-Man series,
it was obvious that Sony had completely lost
its way with Spidey.
The MCU resurrected his box office fortunes,
giving Sony Pictures, which reaped all the
profits from web-head's MCU-set solo adventures,
not only its top-performing Spider-Man film,
but the highest-grossing flick in its history
with the wall-crawler's MCU swan song, Spider-Man:
Far From Home.
Fans may love Holland, but it's hard to imagine
his next appearance in the Sony Universe of
Marvel Characters will resonate the same way
his appearances in the MCU have.
And who knows how Marvel will have to change
things up now that they don't have Spider-man
around?
"I don't think Tony would have done what he
did if he didn't know that you were going
to be here after he was gone."
Of course, there's still time for Sony to
come to its senses and invite Mighty Marvel
back to the bargaining table, but at the moment,
it appears that the studio is intent on learning
what fans don't want, the hard way.
Again.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.